you were bored during the making of your
last album so that's why you decided to
write a book well it's just you know
it's a friend of mine you know i love
after dinner stories and my and i love
listening to them and i love people
because it's a lost art right not a joke
right i mean a wonderful story story
and my friend said run your grit and why
didn't you write them down he does have
great stories when you were a young man
and you you got to open up for chuck
berry for example yes like that was
insane right he's one of the idols right
and he we supported him for a week in
germany
and uh he and at the end of that week i
never bothered him he used all of our
equipment everything free grab us we
just said no you have it and at the end
i said can i have an autograph mr berry
please
and he went i did one autograph a day
and i've already done it
he does one autograph a day and he's
already done i said well it's i'm brian
johnson the singer from geordi that you
know and we've lent you all our
equipment i just just even
he said you're from scotland i said no
i'm not actually i'm from england he
said if i say you're from scotland
you're from scotland i said
you know i said
so i told him a few things which i can't
even see on here paul newman was a
famous actor you met him he thought you
were part of his race car driving teams
yeah he i guess brian i don't know for
some reason doesn't look like a rock
star
and so paul newman assumed you know paul
newman was a racist part of the crew he
thought that brian was part of the crew
oh my goodness did you go along with it
and just work on his car well i mean you
are skilled in that well i do you know i
used to i've been with him i've met him
a few times at race meetings at drivers
drivers meetings and uh because we're
raced in the same races together right
and he uh
and he invited us up to the vancouver
grand prix and i was standing there in
the pits with some of these guys and it
was raining and then it stopped raining
and it was raining and they didn't know
whether to put wet or dried tears on and
you still stand beside him and he looked
at me and he said well what do you think
let her dry and i just went you know
paul
i don't work for you
[Laughter]
are you sure i'm absolutely positive he
said well i've seen you so many times
around that said i know but i'm in a
band called they're saying
oh you're right i've heard of you i said
no yeah
you